normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government this
is from The Daily Mail Millennial women
in the US are facing the first active
decline in well-being since World War II
with suicides debt and cost of living
all skyrocketing in the previous segment
we're talking about surrogacy you're
mentioning there are many women who just
need the money is this a component of
why this is happening young women who
don't have support systems are unable to
support themselves and are turning to
things like selling their eggs or
surrogacy and it's not just a a
situation here in the United States it's
also a very big situation in Ukraine
where human trafficking has increased
dramatically and a lot of uh particular
operations are currently underway there
where uh a lot of women are used as ccat
there uh because a lot of American
dollars are a lot more uh powerful in in
Ukraine than the are here in the United
States so those operations happen
internationally they happen at a grand
scale they're happening at a huge scale
right now in Ukraine where a lot of
where law enforcement is tied up where a
lot of people are saying that that
Ukraine's number one export right now is
babies that are born through Surat
through uh this this larger conflict
that has opened the door for it more
than ever yeah a conflict that by the
way zalinski is in Washington DC4 and
asking for an additional $61 billion to
continue and prolong as this people are
being sacrificed in more ways than one
not just on the front lines I I I do
want to point this out right away as
we're starting the segment they're
tracking young women's well-being I'm
willing to bet young men's well-being is
substantially lower oh 100% AB this
metric is not relevant to to relative to
anything but women to women of previous
generations you add men on there and men
are like but pH just said women are
going to complain that
they're the sexual revolution has been a
disaster for the human race yeah it has
the sexual Revolution and its cons qu
have been a disaster for the human race
and it's and that is honestly probably
true like I mean the the level of
unhappiness is unprecedented and we've
never had at least in the west like fine
we're not the Pinnacle anymore we're not
the richest we've ever been because the
value of the dollar Etc but we're still
pretty far up there when it comes to you
know the ability to produce the things
that we need to sustain Our Lives you
know very rarely do people die of you
know something like uh um not being able
to get enough food you know you don't
starve in the in the in the west anymore
yeah we got fat homeless people yeah
obesity is the biggest problem of our
poor which is a huge contradiction but
it's true I mean that's that's the level
of opulence but but I I agree with you
and and and what you were just saying
how it's been tragic for for for
well-being and for happiness what's
what's your average 22-year-old female
you know with this lousy Harvard degree
as we were saying or with no degree
who's she dating a guy who can't find a
job who you know who was probably aat
and and beta and and been brow beating
his entire life to all these toxically
masculine so she there's no masculine
guys and that and I think you Luke are
complicating no offense the sperm count
egg count thing I think if you tested a
22-year-old guy and a 22-year old girl
their sperm and egg are great but the
problem is by the time they're ready to
kids quote unquote ready they're 38
you're not supposed to have kids at 30
you're allowed to have kids I'm I'm I'm
48 right you're allowed to have kids at
38 but the body genetically biologically
is ready to have kids like my parents
did when you're 20 your body's ready to
have kids long before your brain is
ready and that's like like Evolution
figured it out that's why the the birth
rates are going down your childbearing
years for a woman are in your early 20s
and I'm not saying I'm going to get all
the ha
it's even earlier but but if you go back
to our grandparents generation my
parents generation if you got married at
19 and 20 and had kids at 21 and 22
sperm and egg are not a problem I think
but by the time you're 38 and maybe you
have had a laptop on your lap for 17
more add years and a cell phone Glu to
your but you're also now 38 and a 38y
old body is not the same absolutely as a
there's a lot of decomposing and
breaking down of the DNA structures
particularly uh this affects more women
than men it also does affect men as well
but who can have a kid at 22 if if you
have $300,000 degree from Harvard a debt
from Harvard you have a degree that does
absolutely nothing you can find a job
you still live with your parents theal
you don't want to have a kid because of
climate
change actually those are the ones I'm
glad don't have kids when they say like
we're not going to have kids for the
climate they're glad too it's a Winn
absolutely that's what I'm saying we
don't want your kind reproducing if blue
States want a Bor to the point of birth
then it's just like well okay I guess so
the point that you're making right now
and the point that you've made multiple
times about how the conservatives are
going to take over the culture because
of birth rates and stuff like that the
uh what if Al his uh ruard who does that
that YouTube channel he was talking to
sitchin Adam on a stream today and he'
mentioned that the the Muslim world was
very secular before the Ottoman Empire
and then the the M Muslims stopped
having a lot of kids and the really
religious people literally the secular
people stopped having kids yeah the
secular stopped having kids and really
religious people started T having a lot
of kids and that's why the Muslim world
is so is so you know it's the phenomenon
that you outlined here in the west that
has already happened so allegedly I
don't I haven't can I just can I say I'm
imagining how awesome Christmas is going
to be in 20 years you know the war on
Christmas will be over they'll stop
saying happy holidays they'll start
saying Merry Christmas again I think it
might take a little longer than 20 years
but yeah maybe 40 but uh the point I
often bring up is this is back in like
2017 2018 when I did this research
numerous studies saying that in the in
the 2000s liberals were having 1.43 kids
and conservatives having 2.05 whatever
the numbers are and that means today for
you're going to see it's it's 20 years
later people voting Republicans are for
for every four people you have you have
three
Republicans and you have uh one Democrat
so you know I I or or you could argue
it's like you know two and a half one
and a half or whatever but uh also I
understand there's also indoctrination
and things like that but that is not as
powerful you your formative years are
the most important years of your life so
you're growing up with a conservative
family then maybe your 15th or whatever
going to high school and they start
giving you the weird woke crap I know
it's happening in younger and younger
ages now but conservatives are pushing
back against this because it's offensive
to them well with the way that things
are going with immigration I don't think
you're going to be you're going to be
saying Merry Christmas I think you're
going to be saying Fel Navidad that's
fine I'm totally okay with that thank
you Muhammad I appreciate you and no no
it's going to be Feliz Navidad and Merry
Christmas and both are acceptable Feliz
Navidad I love Feliz Navidad that's a
good song it's going to be European cuz
all South America was you know uh was
from the Spanish anyway so I'm not I I
don't I don't care what language people
speak you know I I think there's an
important cohesion for society in
language that matters but my point was
simply like y these
people despise traditions and they are
bad traditions but American traditions
there's a lot of really really great
ones and who doesn't love a nice
Christmas yeah now I we have we have
Jewish friends here and they're
celebrating Hanukkah and that's really
really awesome too I don't know anything
about it I got no beef with Hanukkah I
just like Christmas and I'm just saying
we're going to have based AF Christmas
in a couple Generations because
Christians reproduce more than liberals
do well that's why they hate tradition
and it's also why as you were saying if
you have this influx of of conservatives
of right of Center let's just say that
having children and this population is
growing but then they get to school and
they start hearing all this W crap and
the parents push back that's why we had
to declare all the parents as domestic
terrorists right you have to go after
the parents you can't allow them to go
after school boards you can't allow them
to say like we want to know what our
curriculum is if it weren't for Co not
that Co had a good side but if it
weren't for Co how many parents would
even know what their kids were still
learning the only reason why they
learned it is because they sat in the
front of the the computer screen with
their kids and they were like whoa whoa
whoa what the hell is this let's let's
let's talk about right now we already
have the the the phenomenon 20 years ago
where conservatives are having more kids
and a lot of people say oh but you know
immigration immigration like well well a
lot of immigrants are Christians okay so
Perhaps Perhaps the concern is there'll
be less and less white people I think
white people are concerned about that
okay look if they move to Blue states
where abortion is legal to the point of
birth it doesn't matter if you're an
immigrant or a native born American the
likelihood you have an abortion is
infinity is infinitely higher why
because in the red States it's
zero the red states are are Banning it
you ain't have an abortion there was
already a report I saw that said 32,000
new births attributed to the Banning of
abortion you might actually start seeing
population growth come back I mean
because what what are we seeing right
now with Millennials it's like
population decline it's below rep
placement levels in red States it's
probably going to go above repl levels
cuz what what were you saying Phil your
body is ready before your brain is your
body is ready so a lot of these a lot of
these kids with the brain's not ready
are going to be having kids anyway so
the 32,000 kids that were now born
because abortion was not allowed so if
you're looking for the surrogacy option
just skip the whole Avenue and just go
to an adoption if you really want a kid
go adopt kid because because these many
of these guys want the kid to be part of
them and so I think one of the reason
we're saying these guys all have two
kids is that each of them gets to be the
father to one of the kids I don't know
exactly what their plan is and how they
have they done it but that seems to make
a lot of sense in many of these
instances you see two fathers having two
kids then each of them gets to pass on
their
genetics hey man I'll tell you it's not
even as crazy as you think it's going to
get there there there there already like
in China I'm pretty sure they're
programming babies they have genetic
super soldiers that they're literally
mixing DNA and getting the strong
strains of to have want to 65 we want to
be built no cancer High pain tolerance
yep so we're we're work out well oh man
we're we're not that far away from
people just be like I don't want my kid
to wear glasses you know I want my kid's
hair to be blonde all that stuff you
could already pick out uh the genetics
of your children there's a lot of
companies out there that take the
ovaries of the mother the sperm of the
male they bring them together and
they're like okay you're going to have a
child that's going to be 5'9 oh this
match here says it's going to be 6'1
which set of of of children do you want
that we're going to reimplant into your
ovaries that's already happing uh other
governments the US government already
has done this the Chinese government is
is doing this the Russian government is
doing this I'm convinced and I'm kind of
being a little fous here that a lot of
the UFC dagestanis are probably Russian
super soldiers because if you look at
their domination uh at at the UFC it's
very apparent that that of course Uh
something's up here that they all look
the same they all have the same beards
they all have the same kind of fighting
techniques and they dominate the sports
especially when it comes to wrestling in
a way that a lot of people haven't seen
before so I think I think there there
absolutely is a genetic super soldier
program um in the United States in China
in dagistan everywhere and imagine 20
years from now all of a sudden something
happens where we get numerous reports of
20-year-olds developing strange rare
forms of cancer M and then the Scandal
breaks that in 2023 several clinics
started doing crisper and other genetic
modification telling the parents that it
was going to be okay 20 years later
these adults are like what's happening
and they're getting tumors on their body
and weird things are happening it's
inevitable you can't I I I China's
literally I'm sorry to to cut you off I
just I I just remember this cuz we
talked about this on the show uh when I
was here last time they're working on
specific genes that allow soldiers to be
uh to to have them survive nuclear
fallout that's that's literally what
that's literally the plot of Fallout 3
yes I think that's literally what the
Chinese government forc evolutionary
virus and turned everyone into super
mutants and reduced their brain capacity
and made them all very stupid yeah sorry
I I cut you off no no no that would be
pretty remarkable cuz I mean their their
bodies are still flesh and and blood so
I wonder how they survive nuclear
fallout still being cockroaches do
cockroaches do yeah but they're not
flesh and blood like we are you know
they're a different exos I guess you
have to create a different exoskeleton I
mean I don't I don't think the exos
skeleton uh protects them from from
radiation I don't know but I mean
something does the well I mean it's just
that the the I don't know anything about
cockroaches but the the fact of the
matter is there are you know life forms
that respond to radiation differently so
you know I don't know that you can but I
I do think that it's fairly obvious that
governments are going to do everything
heinous and horrible that you can
imagine times 10 yeah because they
already have like the this there there
may be attempts to moderate in Western
democracies some place like China
there's probably not um you know place
like Russia there's probably not that's
why Echo Health Alliance Dr fouchy they
went all went over there to weaponize
viruses yeah exactly and I don't think
that it's I don't think that that it's
re reasonable to think that the
government wouldn't and when you're you
you know whatever the question is the
government probably would so you know
you're going to have all kinds of things
I think the US government is probably
less interested and this is just my gut
I think the US government is less
interested in making human uh hybrids
than it is uh making robotics I think
the US is more interested in having
robots do the job and having having
humans interface via stuff like drones
or whether it be neuralink or whatever
but I think the US is more interested in
having robots do it where whereas some
place like China or Russia might be like
actually just go ahead and crisper them
into mutants thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net